thank you
[Music]
all right we're back with the vivacious
my partner in all things Joy crime Carla
Hall and now we're getting crafty
Thanksgiving is a time to appreciate and
give thanks to the ones that you love
and what a better way to do that than
with a homemade gift you know what's
interesting
um is that they did a survey and they
asked people like in a poll like what
kind of presents do you like the most
and do you know what the answer was
like handmade handmade yeah something
you can't buy in a store okay I agree
I'd be way mads I mean just anything
that somebody made for you means so much
more
um but here to teach us all the
Thanksgiving crafts we could ever need
and more is my very good friend and the
owner of the craft studio Lindsay piers
hi guys hi Lindsay I'm so excited to be
here and I can't wait to do this with
you guys
well I want to know what we're crafting
today but we can't like talk about like
I see popcorn I see candy corns I see
all things corn and we can't talk about
corn on this show without talking about
the corn Kim himself ladies and
gentlemen it's my dear friend Tariq yeah
I am ready to grab all right I'm ready
[Applause]
and nobody is better than Lindsay her
craft Studios you have multiple
locations in New York if you're here you
got to hit them up I've been taking my
daughters there since they were born and
Lindsay is just the most thoughtful mom
herself and so take it away okay what an
introduction oh my goodness so what
better for Thanksgiving than a
cornucopia craft that you can give or
you can use as a place setting they're
so easy to make and I'll start to tell
you about it and let's get cracking you
have a sheet of paper
could I see if I know the rules even if
I haven't ever made one you think you
might know yes like what do you think I
think we have to cut out this semi
circle
grown up and put candy in it and put
Happy Thanksgiving I am thankful for
clothes
sometimes
[Applause]
like kept more of the paper so kind of
be easy oh yeah you be easy that's such
a good point anytime you work with
scissors you should you should be easy
what do we do with the half circles once
we've got them
no you go right now I love this you you
tell us yes
[Applause]
a pro and you can just tuck one of the
flat side corners and start rolling you
did it wrong no there are no mistakes in
our and perfect is boring let's remember
that I think she means something like
yes yes get it yes oh yeah way better
yeah way better yeah look like this
right
um Carla how are you doing over there
and also a good question what are you
thankful for at this time over here I am
thankful one for my health my husband
who's so supportive and I have to give a
shout out to my mom and my in-laws
because we're going there for
Thanksgiving dinner
you'll have a new table escaping yeah
that's what I'm saying
um what do you think um is this okay
that's amazing I mean you can just start
rolling yeah I love it and then this is
the fun part you guys think about what
you want to fill it with these are
Treats but look at these beautiful
accent feathers to make it look nice you
can put your thankful message I love a
moment of gratitude that can even be a
part of the process that this is an
activity
look at this I was like Yay
we have foil wrapped chocolates and this
is my favorite part it's magical edible
glitter so if it gets on that Carlos is
right up here on the baking challenge
it's amazing I read about that in the
news yeah do you eat edible glitter on
your cereal Tariq
would you eat glitter on your cereal yes
yeah me too I think I'm with you I love
it I love it too I love it too and it's
Cornucopia should we eat two uh corn
two corns up or oh yeah corn up I'm
hoping it's corn up two corns up
um I give it
a cone up
in my opinion I don't know if this was
the point but I'm going straight to some
tablescaping here Lindsay yes um and you
could also make little banners things
are great for attitude messages Tariq
what are you grateful for I I'm grateful
for Drew and everybody here
[Applause]
so kind you and your mom
very important friends in my life I feel
so lucky I know I that's so kind Lindsay
what do you think of my I love it oh yes
yes right look at that church
I know what are you grateful for
I love it
um I am grateful for health and
I am grateful for health and time with
family and and time here with you all
I'm so grateful my family's healthy and
we're gonna get to be together and I
think that's all that matters is health
and togetherness I'm gonna say that I'm
really grateful for Tariq because I
really have gotten to know your mom and
I've spent quite a bit of time with her
and I'm just I I had such a deep
connection with you and it's so sweet
I I think you're such a gift in this
world and everybody really like
responded to you and they were drawn to
you and that's so wonderful but you
really are like a true light in this
world and I'm just so grateful that like
we get to be in each other's lives
yeah I really am so beautiful so
beautiful not it's not often you make
new friends and when you do it's just so
meaningful and Drew I think we could all
say how grateful we are that you are in
our lives yeah and yeah
[Music]